Tonight, Americans already
slammed by soaring prices
now getting hit even harder.
New numbers showing inflation
surging to its fastest pace
in nearly 40 years.
The consumer price index, or CPI,
tracks the cost of everyday items.
It's jacked up a whopping
6.8% in the last year,
the biggest increase in almost 40 years.
Gas is up 51%, beef is up
20%, and furniture by 11%.
I think probably in June,
it was about, a dollar is worth a dollar.
So now that dollar is
worth about seventy cents.
This has made the "Nightly News"
sound a little too much like
a rerun of "That '70s Show,"
a sitcom set in a decade
famous for ever rising prices
and useless Whip Inflation Now buttons
that Gerald Ford tried
to stick on everybody
from running mate, Bob Dole,
to former Beatle George Harrison.
Back in the 1970s, President
Ford was better known
for literally and figuratively stumbling
than for his economic acumen.
Especially when it came to inflation,
which soared into double digits
shortly after he took office.
Ford believed that the
way to beat inflation
was to brow beat companies
into keeping prices down
and Americans into
becoming bargain hunters.
He declared a war on high prices,
referring to inflation as
domestic enemy number one.
"I pledge to my fellow
citizens that I will buy,
"when possible, only those
products and services
"priced at or below present
levels," promised Ford.
Joe Biden is looking reminiscent
of the 38th president,
and not simply because he also has trouble
with airplane steps.
Biden, his advisors and
champions in the press
are ignoring the tough lessons of the past
by downplaying inflation
or bizarrely claiming it
only freaks out rich people.
Then there's leading Democrats,
like Senator Elizabeth Warren,
who seem to be channeling
Gerald Ford when she tweeted out
that the reason your
Thanksgiving groceries
cost more this year was
because greedy corporations
are charging Americans extra
just to keep their stock prices high.
Even worse, Biden and crew
are delusionally pronouncing
that we can tame inflation
by pumping massive amounts
of money into the economy.
A course of action that
will almost certainly
make everything more expensive.
What Ford, Biden, Warren,
and Treasury Secretary
Janet Yellen have in common
is a failure to understand
inflation's most important
underlying cause,
which the Nobel prize winning
economist, Milton Friedman,
was explaining with unique
clarity back in the 1970s.
To our understanding
the cause of inflation,
is to recognize that it
is always and everywhere,
a monetary phenomenon.
We've seen massive increases
in government spending
over the past two years,
which have been paid for by printing money
and historic increases
in the money supply.
And when you print money,
it means that there are more dollars
chasing the same amounts
of goods and services,
which causes prices to rise.
In just the past two fiscal years,
federal spending has swollen
to nearly $7 trillion a year,
up from about $4.5 trillion in 2019.
That money has to be paid for eventually
by the American people one way or another.
Traditionally, that means higher taxes,
cuts in services, and inflation,
or a combination of the three.
The real tax on the American people
is what government spends.
And politicians generally
prefer printing money
to raising taxes or cutting services.
Inflation is a tax,
which is imposed without representation
and which nobody has to vote for.
And of course, it's a marvelous
tax from the point of view
of a Congressman trying to meet
the demands of his
constituents for more spending.
Politicians and government economists
will even claim that the
way to drive down inflation
is by handing out more goodies.
Yeah.
What this package will do
is lower some of the most important costs,
what they pay for health
care, for childcare,
and it's anti inflationary
in that sense as well.
- When the President and his advisors
touted the passage of his $1.2
trillion infrastructure bill,
and promised that even more was on the way
through the Build Back Better
bill and other legislation,
they insisted that spending more money
will somehow make
everything more affordable
by increasing long-term economic capacity.
- According to economic experts,
this bill is gonna ease
inflationary pressures,
lowering the cost of working families.
17, excuse me, yes, 17
Nobel laureates in economics
wrote a letter to me saying,
this is gonna affect, bring
inflation down, not up.
- That's precisely backward,
because the government will
be printing even more money
to pay for Biden's bill.
As the government borrows more money
to pay for its spending,
and the Fed prints money to buy that debt,
the Central Bank's balance
sheet has more than doubled
between March 2020 to November 2021.
The result is that the supply
of dollars has increased
by nearly 40% over the past two years,
which is an off the charts record.
But there's no reason to believe
that Joe Biden or anyone
else in Washington
is committed to the type of
fiscal and monetary discipline
that would actually tame inflation.
In fact, his infrastructure bill
jacks the very entitlement spending
that is the major driver
of long-term spending.
Not only is he trying to expand access to
and coverage offered by existing programs,
such as Medicare and Medicaid,
he's pushing for tax credits for parents,
and new entitlements for
childcare and universal preschool.
Another thing that's changed
over the past 40 years
is that the publicly held debt
has more than quintupled
as a share of GDP.
In 2022, the Congressional Budget Office
predicts that interest
payments on the debt
will be 5.7% of total spending.
And then it will more than
double to 11.6% by 2031.
And that's assuming
interest rates stay low.
Squeezing inflation out of the economy
by hiking interest rates
is never a popular political stance.
Since it will absolutely devastate
the government's balance sheet,
it'll be even harder this time.
- Inflation is just like alcoholism.
In both cases, when you start drinking,
or when you start printing too much money,
the good effects come first,
and the bad effects only come later.
- And get this. Even the
price of booze is going up.
So not only will we have more sorrows,
it's gonna cost us more to drown them.